CARTER MORGAN:
Today, we're talking
about Looker machine-learning
courses and Secop updates.
I'm Carter Morgan, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest-latency news.
Registration is now open for
Google Cloud Next, October 12
to 14.
Much like Google Cloud,
this year's flagship event
is designed to be
open and flexible,
and gives you the
freedom of choice
to create the experience
that's best for you.
We've designed "Next '21" as a
customizable digital adventure
to allow for more
personalized journey.
We're releasing a new set of
features as part of Looker 21
that will enable organizations
to build critical data
experiences and innovative
data products faster, as well
as extend their insights into
more areas of the business
with packaged analytics.
Faster application development,
more multi-cloud environment
support, and more accessible
insights are just a few
of the new offerings
of Looker 21.
Check out the product features
guide for full details.
If you couldn't attend our live
ML Academy webinar on July 22,
you can now watch it
on demand and take
advantage of free Coursera
courses on ML until August 31.
Prepare for the Google Cloud
Professional Machine Learning
Engineer Certification
exam, and show your skills
with badges from our
skills challenge.
Get started today.
We're thrilled to announce
Autonomic Security Operations--
a stack of products,
integrations, blueprints,
technical content, and
an accelerator program
to enable customers
to take advantage
of our best-in-class
technology stack
but on Chronicle and Google's
Deep Security Operations
Expertise.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
And we'll see you in the Cloud.